all right well thank you very much
welcome to the second half of Lydia's
tutorial and uh well may as well get
started
Lydia okay welcome back so just to recap
what we've done in the first part of the
first part which I thought would be just
the first part we talked about
information and work you know these two
concepts are related and then in the
second part of the first part we started
talking about treating thermodynamics as
a resource theory and I introduced his
framework of thermal operations while we
allow for unit areas that conserve
energy in entropy and we allow for
thermal States as modeled by give states
to be connected to my system okay and
then we talked a little bit about what
is the assumption of of thermal States
is partially justified and he saw that
there's still some open questions and
there's still some open questions about
why we allow for unit areas at all okay
so we have this model which is a very
simple kind of toy model and we're gonna
see what we can do with it so first
let's look at a simple example which is
when the Hamiltonian is a generate so
then what you get you allowed all the
all the unitary operations and you're
allowed we're allowed give States but
give States on a deterrence hamiltonian
just mean a fully mixed age so this is
the framework of noisy operations you
loud mix and sillas and you allows
unitary operations so if you have this
the order that you get in your states in
in your resources is the Majora's Asian
okay and so first just formula here and
then we'll see how to visualize it so
this just means that if you order the
eigenvalues of the states then starting
from from the biggest eigenvalue once
said this someone one side is always
bigger than the son
on the other side so this is for all
okay so what this means here essential
is that row is more pure than Sigma and
we look into this in a in a moment
there's a very nice review of this
framework by Gore and Nicole and Rob's
beckons and some other people so what
you gets if you have this kind of this
kind of pre-order on your set of
resources then your monotones are all
they should convex functions so in
particular you have this thing here
which is the divergence or the Renny
divergence to a set of free states so
this is so some of you are very familiar
with this and I will not say anything
new for the others this is almost like
like an isometric kind of distance
measure it's not a distance because it's
asymmetric
but acts like this so it's a monitor
that is operations and the the causes
that the more similar that row is to the
state on the right than the small the
smaller this is okay and the classical
formulation is like this and then there
are several quantum generalizations they
all have different properties they are
useful for different things and as we
will see well in this case it doesn't
matter because since all unit areas are
allowed you can always diagonal as every
state so therefore you like essentially
back in the classical case okay and
later on it will matter but will not go
in much detail about this so you can use
these guys to define entropies and
therefore all the entropies are are also
monotone under this which makes sense so
how do you visualize this preorder one
very popular tool is to build the so
called Lorentz curves so let's see what
this means
so first you have your your state and
you know how normally you can represent
probability distributions like this kind
of bar graph okay where he is like the
probability
the first out coming of the second and
third for example for this day that is
green and this state would be maximally
mixed it
yes it's be the next okay so you just
sort your eigenvalues and then you build
a step sine function from this which
looks like this so here we have three
different states and then you integrate
these steps function yep and you get the
Lorenz curve so straight lines
corresponds to the to the maximum extent
and all the others are kind of above the
straight line and now how do you how do
you visualize your pre-order here so
it's very simple if one if one curve is
completely above the other then it can
be transformed then you can do this
transformation right so for example you
can choose from the green state into
this into this maximally mixed age yes
into the orange stage because it's
completely above each other it's to this
this condition corresponds to this
condition here but for example it cannot
transform this green to the bull nor can
you transform the blue into the green in
a simple case yes okay
and then you can say okay so this is in
the simple example you get into pieces
as monotones you get this very nice
pre-order let's see what happens if if
now you allow for full hamiltonians and
actually in this case I don't want to
say that little is known but there's
still a lot to to explore so for example
we have a pre-order for block diagonal
studs so these are states that are block
diagonal in the energy eigenbasis so we
could almost call them classical stage
yes so you don't have coherence is
between different different levels
different energy levels and in this case
it - it will be the priority to get its
thermal major ization which is kind of a
rescale metallization we'll go into this
in a bit the mono turns again not
surprisingly the relative entropy to the
thermal stage is a monotone so in
general there's a nice result by Guren
and Brando you know if you have some
kind of a measure that behaves more or
less like a distance and you you
computed towards the the Gibbs towards
the free stage then this will always be
a monotone in your resource theory under
some assumptions yes and then you're
going to get this risk a lawrence curves
and if you want to nice reviews on them
there's this paper by juror Ennis and
also by orders can open him so how do
you build now this this Lorenz curve so
the idea is that before the only thing
that matter was the probability is they
needed to be ordered
so more pure states are better but now
you kind of have to wait this with the
energies so the way to do it is you
first need to reschedule your
eigenvalues multiply them by the kind of
the energy of your stage yes like this
and sort them again from bigger to
smaller then you build your step
function again where this this things
here just means that you you kind of
stretch this x axis such that in the end
the function has this kind of boundaries
of like being it would be like from one
here
and all the way up one here okay it's
just so that it's easier to compare
systems of different sizes for example
states of different systems yes sir
you built this you risk kill them you
build a step function you integrate you
get to Lawrence curve which is just like
the other one yes and then you have
again a nice visual visualization and I
think I don't know if Jonathan will talk
about this in his talk or Carlow going
to more detail but if you read any
papers about thermal operations you'll
see this this Lawrence curves all the
time okay and then again the pre-order
is the same so it just tells you that if
one curve is always above the other then
you can do the transformation so yes so
I'll talk about what is the sufficient
condition what's the necessary condition
so one thing that you get from here so
this pre-order as I said he's only it's
only completely the final on on block
diagonal stays okay so then but what you
get from this is that you get that the
free orange is free and Isaiah monotones
for all states including coherent States
yes and what are these free energies so
essentially there are a rescaled
divergence so you take this thing that
you knew was a monotone and then I
multiplied by Katie okay and I need to
take away this lock that which is a
constant that depends on landed on your
Hamiltonian so why why I mean we had
such a nice monotone why are we
transforming into into into this it
seems like there's no added value and
the added value is just to relate this
to the normal thermodynamics okay so for
classic states this is also a necessary
condition so in particular if you if you
go for that use here is one then what
you get is a trace of the it's kind of
the average energy of your stage my name
is Katie the entropy of the state and
this is the pre energy in traditional
thermodynamics so what we've done here
so what we've done here was to simply
you know to start with this very almost
naive model of just saying well we'll
only allow for unit Ares let's preserve
energy and then we allow for the gift
sites to come for free and then see that
we are we already recovering a
thermodynamic low and quantities that we
had in thermodynamics plus now that we
have a quantum state in the earth lots
of states out of equilibrium we get a
whole family of them ok as you can
change this parameter alpha here and you
get a whole family of of monotones that
for classical states are also form
sufficient conditions necessary
condition system and these are scaling
in particular what it does is that if
you evaluate this on a pure state of a
certain energy then it gives you just
this energy ok so what the free energy
tries to encode is kind of the work
value of your stage because it means
that you could you could transform it to
like a weight that you live to exactly 2
e okay so this is kind of the mode
hopefully very convincing application of
this framework telling you that well we
do get something useful out of it so
there's also many realizations of the
third law that you can get from here by
using other monotones which tell so what
the third law tells us that you cannot
call something to the ground state if
you're near finite resources you need an
infinite time or an infinite path or
variations over this ok so there's
different results that recover this we
already sold and ours principle being
like the world cost operating a system
in the presence of a memory and we saw
this this result is kind of for the
average case if you have many copies but
there's also single-shot results that
use the way you can have like a
probability of error that things can go
wrong with some small probability you
have some tolerance and then the entropy
that come up obviously are not then the
phenomenon Trippi but some
not a single shot in trapeze okay so
this is very nice voice to give a
physical interpretation to your to your
information theoretical entropies and
clearly if you have some finite size
effects like your bath is finite then
this limits the efficiency of your of
your procedure this because if you
remember the protocol to do this erasure
it assumed that she had access to like a
heat but that was as big as I wanted Y
could draw whatever qubits I wanted and
now if you want to study more realistic
situations where this is not the case
then you get all this finite size
effects okay now something that I will
not talk about much because Jonathan
will go into more detail later in the
week our for tuition theorems which what
they tell you is well these results are
kind of average results so what is the
probability of things go wrong or how
badly can things go wrong and what they
tell is that this probability is
exponentially suppressed on on the kind
of variation that you'd get and this is
say it sounds like how would you even
quantify this violation of the of the
entropy so of the expected energy that
you can extract from a process or not so
one thing that you could do is just well
measure my measure my energy reservoir
in the beginning the measuring at the
end and then use this as the work
extracted but of course that if you have
a coherent process then you end up also
with a coherent state in your in your
reservoir and then you have to be much
more careful about how you model of this
so like in the same way that he had to
be more careful when a quantum memory
could not just reduce now here in this
case you also have to treat these things
okay okay
so the other thing that you can do is
well we have this framework where we
have only one conserved quantity which
is the energy okay we only care about
the energy and now say well maybe in
real life there's also other laws like
momentum conservation or some you know
some other quantity that needs to be
preserved and then let's see well let's
just expand the framework and what we
say now okay so now we have these other
observables and our unitary also needs
to commute with them so it cannot add
any momentum or Canada these are things
so what do we get from here well we had
essentially all most of the same results
but now for a different for a different
kind of gibbsite generalize give States
okay we're just happy you have kind of a
different effective temperature for each
of this for each of these observables
and again all this typicality
thermalization
results apply so in particularly static
thermalization results so if you take a
maximal mixed state on the big system
then locally it appears to be like this
yes also the passivity results also hold
here and the monotones you get not
surprisingly you get again this fake
distance this divergence to thee to the
generalize Gibb State and we're starting
to see the first protocols to try to
convert between these two between all of
these quantities so for example you
could have one reservoir that from the
source energy in one reservoir that only
stores spin but has a degenerate
Hamiltonian and you want to and you want
to trade between these two quantities
okay and here they're very interesting
effects when these quantities do not
commit in this a nice area to explore
okay
but so far most of them most of this
could have been could have been almost a
classical framework so when we start to
see like real quantum examples or
quantum phenomena
we can start by looking at coherence so
the first thing is that we could be
interested in implementing you know
rotations in your stage like well okay
like we saw before like going from zero
to plus etc that there's our coherence
but in general you always how do you
implement a unitary on the lab you you
shoot a laser at some system okay and
this laser is a very big coherent system
and you can say well actually I want to
account for this for this resource that
I'm using and can i optimize this
resource so one of the first results on
this topic was quite surprising which
was that this coherence is in a way
catalytic so what does this mean
well so suppose that I I model my my
source of coherence as say harmonic
oscillator but if it's a laser then it's
a very large coherent state on this
harmonic oscillator so what are the
properties of this that are important in
order to implement unitary okay so the
properties turn out to be just two
aspects of this so one this M is easy to
understand it's like the lowest occupied
energy level of my say harmonic
oscillator and the other one measures
how well spread these coherence is this
term here and what I mean by what I mean
by these are the relevant properties it
means that if I want to implement some
unitary to some precision epsilon in
some system than the only things that
matter are these okay so then you can
see well I want to implement the unitary
and then what happens to my coherence
reservoir and this is the idea so
there's some back action of course of
implementing it an operation yes
so my reservoir is changed and in
particular the states
gets kind of more stretched but it does
not degrade this relevant parameter here
there's this Delta because it stretches
of course it lowers this M which in the
end it just means that you know the M is
not really important it just means that
at some point if you keep stretching it
you're gonna hit the bottom yes and once
you once you hit the bottom then at some
point it starts affecting your your
total coherence so what can you do well
I can just pump this up with energy yes
I just add energy to this system so this
is interesting because it sounds like
you can trade the code if you start with
some initial coherence then you can just
add energy and keep this coherence for
all practical purposes that you're
interested in yes so in that sense is
what we say that it acts as a as a
catalyst anyway this is in the very
specific case of this of taking our
money causality is actually involved in
both directions then you can start
looking at more realistic reservoirs and
and so for example there's this paper by
people I think in which they give you an
explicit protocol to extract to extract
work from coherent States to implement
any ties in coherent States and then
later to restore the reservoir this okay
there's also quite some work now on from
two years ago on resource series of
coherence that just try to decide the
system and then resource series that
tried to study coherence together with
together with thermodynamics so this is
also an interesting direction to explore
now finally to go back to the question I
was asked before the break
i'm in the-- the elephant in the
framework is that we allow it for all
this unit tears to be applied but of
course that if you apply any today this
means that you you choose a Hamiltonian
you turn it on at some point and then
you turn it off right in order to do
this or your alternate could even be
something that is time dependent okay in
order to do this you actually you need
to have like an explicit clock system
okay that keeps track of everything so
for example in iron traps they sometimes
use extra ions that act as quarks
themselves okay so then we really want
to have like if thermodynamics is about
to count and counting then we want to
account also for this for these
resources so we need to expand our
framework to think about giving agents
less control just say well we can turn
on some interaction then you can turn it
off later but with not very good time
precision so that you force to model
this explicitly so what our first steps
so there's this idea of having an ideal
clock that is just a particle in a line
perfectly coherent and in this case well
its catalytic you can use it as many
time as you want and it's also allows
you to implement your any test perfectly
there's some results now in which you
modify your framework such that you
don't allow for unit errors but you only
allow for thermal contact thermalization
and and now more recent thing there will
be a paper about this by misha i think
there's some explicit models for some
clocks which are finite sized systems
and then they study like how how big how
good this implementation is depending on
the dimension of the clock and how much
the clock is degraded but again this is
a very interesting area for for research
for directions okay and
you know yes
no there isn't in a sense that quarks
are coherence clocks near this coherence
as far as you know yes yes
you know they both use coherence maybe
for one of them you want you know you
want it for a specific application then
you build them differently but yes I
mean you could call them the same yes
yeah I'd say yes
the state is degraded but the parameters
of interest do not
sure it I mean these results assume that
now you apply this code to a different
system so in this sense then it would
not be if you keep applying to the same
system yes otherwise no no it's good
it's good
it stretches to talk okay so the idea is
if used the clock on a system and then
you can use it on a different system
that's okay okay then these parameters
are not change of course if you want to
use the same fork in the same system
then this is a problem yes because then
the errors are correlated in this I
think correct me if I'm wrong but I
don't think it has been much explored
okay so there's one thing that I haven't
talked before I go to open questions in
this whole talk and I didn't know very
well where to put it to fit a story
which are heat engines and small heat
engines okay so I decided to put them
here because heat engines are an example
of autonomous thermal machines or
thermal protocols where precisely you
you just turn on some interaction and
you forget about it you don't need any
explicit control with your own so the
idea bit which is the idea behind
thermal engines is to explore two
resources that are very common so in
this case to heat lots of different
temperature okay so it's like you can
take one to be your environment and take
the other one to be an extra resource
that you have but you just make it very
big and then you want to use this to do
something so in this case it could be
you want to use it to cool some
additional system that is also in a gift
State or it could use it you could want
to use it to extract work yes so like
take care to be a harmonic oscillator
and you want it to pump this up so and
the question was
well how big this is engine need to be
can we do it with only just say imagine
having only here three cubits do you
still get very efficient engines or not
and the result is that yes you can get
Carnot efficiency but let's let's be a
bit careful about what this means
so the idea between this and a bit
behind this engines is you take one
qubit and you put its qubit in contact
with a bath okay so that it thermal eyes
is it but you choose these gaps very
carefully such that they match in some
way that is convenient for an engine so
in this case like this gap Plus this gap
equals that gap so then you can turn on
some interaction and in fact in this
case there are some results that say
most most interactions will do which is
just which is you know energy conserving
so for example in this case it could
mean that if I get this right it could
mean that when this one goes down
exactly and this one goes down and this
one goes up or you can you can change
yes exactly right because I don't know
yes and vice versa if this one goes up
and this one goes up and that one goes
down yes and then you do this in a way
because you know that here you always
get this sight is always getting
thermalized so you always get a gives
distribution here always get give
distribution here and you fine-tune
these probabilities like by fine-tuning
the gap you fine-tune that the
probability that you get such that in
the end the result on this state that is
not getting thermalize all this all the
time for example could be that well I'm
always cooling down this the system here
or the opposite I'm always pumping the
system up yeah and you can do this by
just letting it run and it reaches
current efficiency which is the maximum
efficiency in the
in the in the classical like macroscopic
is now what is the catch well you need
to fine-tune these gaps very carefully
you need to make sure that they actually
thermalized so there is some gap some
cubit in your path that has the same gap
here so that these things actually
thermalized yes so in the end you kind
of still have these some assumptions
that you have infinitely large boss yes
but they are just a bit more in a
different layer okay good so this is
actually something that would be very
cool for applications because if you
have such a thing then you could put it
inside a quantum computer for example
and have this computers of cooling all
time
okay so now
for more ease by the way for more
results on this several papers by a post
cryptic and there's also a few reviews
that I'll talk about at the end yes okay
so now let's talk about open questions
so first my favorite area would be this
clocks in control I think it's where
there's more room for exploration now
and also it gets you know more useful
interesting results so one idea one
thing that we need to work out is what
are the most efficient clocks like what
is even like the best protocol for this
both from the point of view of theory
but also from looking at specific
experiment setups so the second thing
that we can do and it's been done is to
combine all this all this thermal
operations framework with insights from
reference frame frameworks restaurant
frame resort series okay because your
is like a reference then apply
further restrictions like for example
you know it could be that you cannot
have this fine tuning of parts of
hamiltonians in some experiment so what
you have to do is go to an experimental
it's an awesome this is a reasonable
assumption to have and then try to build
a frame up for this then there's not yet
a clean framework to treat this question
of clocks there's not at least I haven't
seen like a cream kind of resource
through formulation of how much control
you give to an agent how you quantify
this there to be something small and
simple to do again seeing how much we
need coherence how much coherence is
involved in this and finally you know
since we're talking about Cox then you
can relate this to more foundational
problems like the problem of time in
coding theory
okay so the other thing is try to make
this whole thing more realistic so try
to make it less of her it's very Coco
more more like a real cow free in the
field so one idea is to have more
operational notions of temperatures so
instead of modeling the bath by this
gifts type is kind of a statistical
approach which we know already that it's
not true it's not a gift set
it's like typically close to give state
but it's not a gift say yep so we can
either try to model this kind of
knowledge of with high probabilities
close to give state or or we can go from
more operational approach so for example
the way temperature is defined by karna
and there's a very nice overview of this
in five months
lecture notes it's just saying okay I
don't know what temperature is but I
know there's some things call this heat
bath and I know there's one parameter
that matters for the purpose of work
extraction okay so then by then seeing
kind of then saying okay then let's
suppose that I have something called
reversible engines okay that I can run
in one way and then the other and the
work out one way is the same as the work
in the other way just just this idea so
I start from the the work energy the
heat engine which is something I can
actually measure right how much what
comes out how much work comes in and
then I see okay so now let's try to
compose this heat engines like say you
know I have a bath that I I'm just going
to call it the reference I'm just gonna
say this parameter is equals one call is
the temperature and see how much work I
can extract from here to another bath
okay and have this define the
temperature of this other path so it's
the whole argument it runs like this and
that later also results in all the laws
of thermodynamics but the idea that I'm
trying to express here is that you don't
start from this notion of temperature
you just start from something operation
like this work that you can measure and
from here you get some parameter ization
of your bath like in this case the
temperature so we could try to
do the same for engines that we know
work in the quantum regime and then say
I'm plugging in a heat bath you know
maybe do this in an experiment I'd I
think it's at a certain temperature but
but let's see how much work I can get
out of this and let's see if I can
parameterize this by a single parameter
which probably not gonna be the case now
there's been lots of work in finite size
effect there's been some work in going
beyond like this idea that the boss is
in a tensor product with with with my
system and going beyond the weak
coupling also to derive all these
thermalization typicality results okay
so this is something is active the other
thing is having some realistic
descriptions of resources for
experimentalist because maybe the
experimentalist doesn't know that his
system is in some some quantum cytro
that described by density matrix but you
know they've done some tomography and
they know some confidence region around
this okay
well then they know some some other
parameters some observable and I want to
know still you know how much work can
extract from such it from such a
resource that I can only describe in
this way so in the way in the same way
that the original developers of
thermodynamics did okay I didn't have
you didn't know the exact state of your
system we just have some some things
called pressure and volume which is the
accessible information now we still have
this I mean in quantum information would
like to think that knows that we have
access to that to the density matrix but
in fact we still have some effective
description and yes so the question is
then how what kind of effective
descriptions do experimentalist give us
and what can we do with them okay yes
and also you know in all this you know
this work we cared a lot about heat and
bulk but it could be that you know extra
Mentalist alia look we have a great way
to cool our systems heat is not a
problem
with access to infinite energy work is
not a problem actually what we care
about is coherence or to care
no coherence times and these are the
relevant resources and we should be
building resource series that take these
things as the relevant things and try to
study them okay so the the the general
message of this section of opens up open
questions is go talk to experimentalists
and ask them what is important for them
and then you know build your models from
there not the other way around
because otherwise what we ask is that we
see lots of experiments in quantum
thermodynamics and some of them seem a
bit contrived that oh we're measuring
work in this way and why in this way
because it fits your your theoretical
model yes but it's not like a work that
you could later use for something else
it's not a very operational or
meaningful in that way yes so we need to
flip this the other way around
okay so the other thing is that since we
saw a thermodynamics is so general and
it's just a resource theory and we
applied it to macroscopic systems and
you apply to quantum systems and we can
try to apply it to other kind of
otologist so we can take for example it
has been some work on this like when
applying it to generalized probability
theories and it still very if you're
very baby steps what's been done here
and you can try to see like Oh what kind
of GP cheese gets at thermodynamic get
thermodynamic laws that resemble our
world or not and could this be a
parameter to try to to restrict and to
read arrive quantum theory like it's
done now with locality and correlations
so the other thing that one can do is
then if you have this if you derive if
you write an axiomatic thermodynamic in
different physical theories then you can
try to relate them and try to see when
they are similar when they are not and
finally
there's a whole EDS CFT field which uses
thermodynamics but some of the notions
use there of a can be seen as a bit
naive for example the notions of
normalization used or the fact that
thermal sites are all represented by the
Gib stage so this kind of things we can
take some similar kind of the operation
inside that you gain from this framework
and try to apply it to other fields of
research yes also like the insight that
information is subjective and
thermalization is subjective and you
always need to model your agent
explicitly could be useful
yeah okay
with this I am reaching the end so
there's a few results there's a few
reviews of which here I'm only repeating
the three that I mentioned during the
talk but there's a few others so this
talks explicit just about quantum
information apply to different areas of
thermodynamics this one you know here
we're very it's a bit you know a bit
like me this talk is a very like broad
overview more to give you intuitions and
not so much going into mathematical
details so if you want a mathematical
detail of a specific part then in this
case and this paper they flash out like
noisy operations really really well okay
and you can see like how these Lorenz
curves come from and how you get all
these monotones etc etc okay so if you
do then later I would like to start your
own resource theory thinking oh let's a
disarray assumption or let's take this
one out then I would definitely
recommend reading this before to see how
one precedes once you have this
operational principles set and finally I
didn't say much about thermalization
results
and this is a very nice review of the
field yes okay know this KP is a wealth
of thermodynamic presentations and
posters these are just the ones I saw
and that's probably more so I encourage
you to to go to all these talks
so in particular Carlo will talk about
resource here where you can you have
these two resources of heat and work so
you don't give the gibbsite for free a
priori but you can't it also has an
explicit resource and you'll export this
so it would be a very nice follow-up to
this talk Jonathan will talk about many
things including filtration serums in
more detail than I've been when I talk
to you yes
and there's also all this process that
you should go to and that's it thank you
very much for it
so questions so you're the this way of
measuring coherence it somehow involves
a choice of a phase right right so
somehow this operator that you bet you
saw Delta plus Delta adjoint it measures
the real part of the of the coherence
does this matter somehow so we got this
measure because it's a measure that
matters right with we thought okay we
have this web this purpose which is
implementing a unitary and then let's
see what's the measure that turns out to
be relevant it turns out to be the real
place you're asking me yes I know that
the question is yes would I times Delta
minus delta dagger B as as good I don't
know but there are people in the room
who do looking at you know yes yes I
mean
further questions the resource theory
that you defined here it can also be
defined in a few class of settings for
example you can imagine a probability
distribution over phase of space that is
and used couple your system to a term
out of state exactly the same way I was
wondering if there is any fundamental
difference between this quantum problem
and classical problem that is defined
only on phases space and I guess the
second part of the question is that what
you call quantum quantum thermodynamics
or coherence the effect of coherence in
content and dynamics isn't it very
similar to just having non equilibrium
probable distributions in classical
setting let's say I can have stationary
distributions and non stationary
distributions so when youwhen you think
about non stationary distributions there
are some extra constraint on the
possible transformation that you can
make from one state to another
that is just due to the time dependence
of this so for example if the initial
the first one is time independent the
second one the finances cannot be time
time dependent so is it really different
the type of constraint that you get in
quantum quantum too many times this is
different from what you're getting
classical exactly classical setting
you know this depends on what you mean
by different yeah I mean you kind of
saying I add one more constraint and
then I get one more resource that is
important in that sense it's very
similar I mean
I guess the quick
I guess the problem is that you want to
implement this quantum transition right
you want to treat this quantum problem
of like I want to I want to prepare this
state that is coherent so in that sense
it's an it's a new problem that you want
to treat
but it's solved with this okay maybe
lying but I think it's all with the same
kind of reference frame kind of approach
that the classical one would be solved
but yes just the fact that it now allows
you to to treat states that it couldn't
treat before right this is the main
think for me yes yes I mean this is and
it's only you know it's only like a
complete family of monotones for
classical state as well yes there might
be more generally quantum aspect but we
have not explored them so much it but
the main thing is that now we can treat
all these quantum transitions as well I
would say I mean
look yes yes yes yes I know yeah I know
what you mean yes yes yeah in some other
things that for example these results on
thermalization and on typicality or
criminalization how much easy to achieve
because you ever because you have a
quantum space which is a largest place
so you got this typicality much more
easily which maybe you could not justify
your assumptions as well if you had a
completely classical theory but and it
really quantum quantum things well we
can you know extract work from quantum
correlations you can't do this man
because he go through but any further
questions alright well if not actually
I've got one so lately I've been I've
stumbled upon a little bit of
controversy about the Landauer limit I
was wondering if you could comment about
whether you've looked at any of these
critiques that have come out within the
last few years about it or whether you
just haven't looked at it do you want to
tell me any specific oh there's like
Norton and some other people came up
with some some critical critical claims
that the land our limit perhaps hadn't
been proved in exactly the ways that
they would like to see it proved and I'm
just wondering if you if you've looked
at that cuz I haven't
not in big detail so what what I've seen
is like Reba tells of things saying well
I mean I wonder principle is a principle
right you know what to prove it you need
to come up with a framework and then you
need to say well these assumptions are
reasonable okay so now here we have a
framework that is you can question all
of these assumptions separately and then
see if if they're visible within this
framework it has been more than proved
you have finite size Corrections you
have no it's new people buy it for
people any paper bag for people from
December say about what happens if now
if your heat bath is not perfectly
independent of of the system you want to
your ways and you get some Corrections
there at work as well at cetera yes so
now I mean if you're talking about an
objection of this type then we'd have to
discuss like what assumptions they would
like to and yes if someone knows but I'm
happy to discuss the assumption if
there's if there's no other questions
let's again think Lydia foreign for an
excellent tutorial
[Applause]